can anyone hear me
all right let me know if anyone comes
near me
alright cool y'all came here okay so
good right now I'm on my phone checking
the chat on my phone because I had to
restart my computer even in the system
preferences the microphone was set for
some reason to an external source even
though I didn't have one plugged in so
I'm just waiting for everything to start
back up including the control room on my
computer so I can see the chat on my
screen and I can see the the stats for
the stream so let me get that running
now hopefully everything is just really
slow right now but it looks like the
stream quality is okay so I can deal
with the slowness so anyway what I was
trying to say before you will let me
know that couldn't hear anything was
that we were gonna do some unit testing
today so we started last week on
Thursday with doing some unit testing we
were just gonna continue on with that
so we had a pull request from leekie it
may have been later on Thursday actually
or maybe Friday that that did some more
stuff that fix some of the issues that
we were having so if you if you're
interested check that out it'll be the
last pull request that was merged and
you can see you see everything that had
changed and he in the in the comments
for the pool request he kind of explains
you know what's Woody's the one
okay I have my my stream control room
back up let me get my chat going and
then we'll be ready to get going we
ready to get started
sorry about all that I thought finally I
would have a live stream from home
without any issues maybe tomorrow maybe
we'll finally get it tomorrow okay I'm
just gonna scroll up quickly and see
what I missed while I was kind of
switching back and forth in the chat
okay looks like everything was related
to the stream being messed up alright so
everything looks okay I have for some
reason I have that little like spinning
rainbow wheel on one of my screens right
now and it won't go away I I don't know
what's up with that but everything else
seems to be working fine so we're gonna
get started and let me switch so y'all
can see what I have on the screen and
let me know if that font size is big
enough for you all max I need to move
this monitor okay let's see what's so
first I'll just show you an example of
what's changed and then we'll just go
we'll just get right to it and start
doing some some unit tests on some of
the other components Amara says hello
Jesse your great teacher thank you I
appreciate that Thanks
okay so we do need to increase the font
size all right let me do that okay I
think this is about as big as I can go
without it being like kind of like too
too big like without it getting
ridiculous
I'm gonna start I want to start this as
well it turned off because I restarted
everything all right okay so before we
were doing the shallow render method and
now we're just doing the regular render
to see really the you know which we
changed here and here from shallow to
render and that's given us a different
snapshot so let's check out that
snapshot over here so in our tests
folder we now have a snap
it's folder and these snapshots get
automatically created whenever we run
yarn yarn units because we're just doing
the unit test now so we're not worried
about the end-to-end test yet so now you
can see what we get here we actually get
a lot I mean this is the the homepage
just a lot on there but it gives us all
the markup that gets rendered from our
index so let's see you know here's our
index dot JSP have a lot here and some
of its like if we're having an example
yes so some of it we have like this card
media but now we see you know that we
actually have all that rendered out and
so instead of just seeing card media
with these props we see what it would
render what it would be rendered as so
anyway that's that's the difference from
what we had before and let's go into I
think the last thing that we were
working on on the last dream was we're
doing some tests for this text section
and we add this this test text and let's
see what we ended up getting so let's
close this out and let's check out our
whoops I forgot to set my timer so let
me let me do that let me move it over
here
okay there's our Pomodoro timer if you
haven't watched before we we time things
we do 25 minutes of code and we take a
five-minute break I go back to live chat
answer questions
oops you know I was gonna open this up
let's open this up
whoa we have quite a lot here
okay yeah this this was where we left
off now I remember I tried to watch some
of the stream from from last week just
to jog my memory since it's been so long
but I didn't I didn't get through all of
it so I think this is where we left off
is that we were we were trying to pass
in text as a prop and we had expected to
see it rendered out you know within as
the text of the component but it wasn't
we were seeing it still as a prop okay
finally okay here we are so we finally
get to it down here this is what I
wanted to see here so at some point we
see what it gets rendered as so good all
right so that passes so I'm not sure why
I mean I said maybe it's rendering it to
different different ways did I miss
something
okay so we do have to 2 times we're
having it matched the snapshot right
yeah okay so here okay yeah so here
we're just saying it should render and
we wanted it to match the snapshot here
we want it to render text okay all right
so that yeah that definitely explains
and I'm pretty sure we talked about this
last time so sorry that I'm repeating
myself here okay but that's what that
works then so we just have to remember
that I gotta go down to the bottom to
actually see what what skinny rendered
all right so it's from what I saw with
the short amount of time that I spent
researching unit testing and this was
last week so basically between last week
when we ended the stream and now I
haven't really done any research with
unit testing so I had the day off Friday
I had the day off yesterday so I wasn't
working on work stuff I did do some
coding but it was on other other
projects you know just side projects so
let's try to do some more tests for each
of the props to guess would be a good
idea to actually look at this component
nope not that one okay so we're getting
passed in title text link button link
button text text color background color
border color
okay let's I'm not exactly sure how we
would test the the color but we can
definitely test some of this other stuff
yeah we'll see if they if they catch the
the color so anyway I from what I study
sorry I stopped I started a thought
earlier and I just didn't finish it is
that you should have you should have
separate it statements for each prop so
shouldn't try to test all the props all
at once right it may take up a lot less
space but I mean think about it I try to
test all the props at once I still then
have to go through and try to figure out
okay well which prop failed so it should
be better to do it like this that's if
anybody has experience with this and
thinks that that's not a good way to do
it let me know there's like I said the
last time I even checked this was last
week so my memory is not like really
great about it Michael asked if I was
working on to all beat this weekend huh
sorry for the aren't I was up the baby
was sick and so I was up with her a
little bit tired yeah so the crypto
zombies tutorial on you know building
things for the blockchain etherion
blockchain with a language called
solidity yeah so I did work on that so
they keep adding lessons so right now
I've run out of lessons but yeah I
worked on that a little bit I worked on
that brainwave headset thing a little
bit I had a video call with Alex
Castillo who's very generously offering
his help with it so we were able to
connect the headset that reads the
brainwaves to via Bluetooth directly to
a browser so that was pretty cool that
was some good progress and then I also
did some work on the JavaScript AF
project you can check out the repo for
that in in my my github profile all
right so let's say it should render
excellent pass render a title when
passed in so we can just change this to
section title and let's try passin I
[Music]
guess we could do a test title and there
you go let's save that why am I getting
the Green Line
okay the course loading snapshot doesn't
exist yet
all right that's that's fine so let's
run yarn units and if you're using NPM
and doing this you could just do NPM
unit or NPM run unit we're using yarn so
we should see a difference in our our
snapshot so we should see a change here
hopefully
okay cool so we can see the color
changed and did it pass we're still
waiting on the index are the index
passed Wow the that took a long time you
know what I think
the tests are taking longer because I
have OBS running so that that makes more
sense
so normally a unit test would not take
that long but let's check out that that
section here and we'll scroll scroll all
the way down since that would have been
let's see I guess not
why is that not the last one all right
let's just find that's a lot to go
through let's find test title okay so
let's see where it's at section title
test I don't all right there we go so
here we actually have it rendered where
it's ought to be rendered inside this h1
all right cool that works I'm not really
sure what's up with the order I would
have thought that it would have been
down lower but all right not bad okay so
I guess you can see you know we can test
that props get properly rendered by the
components so like why just for those of
you who are wondering about testing like
if you haven't done testing you're
wondering like why does this even matter
this seems silly it does it seems kind
of weird like okay this is pretty simple
these props will render but the part of
the point of it is if I or someone else
working on the project went into this
component which where do we have it
somewhere here tech section J s which I
can't even find so let me let me open
that
again so if we went a text section dodge
is you know I think I have it over here
I did have it over here and we changed
something in here right we would change
this if we changed it and somehow it
didn't render props properly anymore
there could be a lot of other places in
our our app where we're using that
component and we're passing in props and
we expect it to do a certain thing and
because of a change we may have
inadvertently chain that caused some of
these props to not render the right way
or not render at all and with a test
we'll catch that automatically so you
wouldn't have to go through every
instance of where that's used it's like
right now this is still somewhat
manageable like potentially you could go
through everywhere where we use that but
in a bigger app that would be insane
every time you make a change to actually
go through all the pages where that's
use and make sure it it renders properly
and eventually this is gonna be really
huge we're gonna have a lot of data
there and we're gonna be using more
components like right now I don't want
to explain all what we're doing right
now with data but right now we're not
using a lot of components at some point
when we get all the data structured like
we want we will be using more components
so literally you would have to check if
you wanted to be sure that everything
was running properly you would have to
check in potentially like hundreds of
pages so you definitely you know you
don't want to have to do that so this is
a way to just put in some sample data
make sure it all renders properly also
these tests will run not only locally
but they'll run in the on github in the
repo with Travis
but in anyway so let me know if anyone
has any more questions about testing or
like
in general about testing I'm not an
expert but you know maybe I could give
offer some advice from the little that I
know or someone else in the check-in can
offer something okay so now that we have
the rationale for why why we're doing
this let's let's just finish this out
actually you know what I do want to test
since I don't know how it will work out
I want to test this one of these colors
right so all the rest of these are going
to be basically adding an element or
adding text within an element but these
three down here are gonna be dealing
with colors okay so let's grab text
color oops I didn't want to grab the
whole thing text color and did I make
another one I didn't I meant to copy
that I totally forgot okay
so let's pass in and text color this is
this is gonna be really interesting
because if we don't pass in text would
text color even matter I'm interested to
see how this would work like do we need
to pass in both so let's just give it a
value I guess we can give it a value of
black I don't think we're actually using
black so we shouldn't get like a false
positive let me say that and let's run
this okay so while that runs I'm gonna
try to keep looking back at the chat
oh wow that was a lot faster I took
about half the time
all right cool so it looks like it yeah
it it looks like it passed why that's
that's kind of weird
what we kept having index thought test
just like keep popping up okay so let's
look at this again and let's see let's
let's search for that there we go so
there we have our text color and let's
see okay so in our or it actually
renders out what the style would be so
that's interesting so we have that style
here and see where else it is okay well
so it did it went on that h1 even though
there's no texture that h1 interesting
alright so it looks like we can test
styles which is I mean that's great then
where we can test the better let's see
I'd like to see the component because it
does seem like we're still getting
things rendering when we don't even have
that value
huh really sorry about all the yawning
so let's let's look back at our
component then I wonder how I built this
I thought I built this so that it
wouldn't even attempt to display this
let's see button I don't need one
okay so where's our
okay here's the title alright so I did
build it I guess it was a mistake and I
I thought I had built it so that it
would only render this if there were a
section title and I guess I did not okay
I did do the button that way so that
makes more sense so you can see I have
the button here as a constant constant
and this renders based on that so it
makes a lot more sense I think to do it
like that
okay I really kind of want to pull this
out now and refactor this but we're
doing testing right now let's not do
that all right so let me know in the
chat if you want me to just finish this
out to do like to test all the props or
we can just move on
excuse me all right we can see I'd like
to try to get a component that's the
kind of does more but I'm not exactly
sure that we have
oh okay yeah let's do our let's do our
drawer because we have let's see let's
check out drawer item for a second on
click okay so we have on clicks
happening here within our drawer item so
I really want to test that
so with Jess we can test a user action
so we can simulate a user clicking and
then make sure that something that
what's supposed to happen actually
happens when a user clicks so that's
that's kind of the last thing that I
definitely want to show on on a stream
because you know so basically we've gone
over like what three things so does the
component render like period does
anything appear okay so that's the first
test the second thing was if you give it
props does it do the right thing with
those props
okay so we've we've tested those two
things and they worked and then now the
third thing is based on a user action
does the right thing happen so if we
cover those three things I think we're
pretty good I'm sure there's probably a
lot more to unit testing but in terms of
this project that's probably going to
cover the majority of the tests that we
write and then between last stream and
this stream hopefully you'll have enough
info to write your own unit test and if
you want to contribute to this project
with writing unit tests you'll have an
example of how to write test for you
know any of the components all right so
let's check out let me go on my other
screen and I want to check out the click
event so I'm gonna go to
the enzyme Doc's on github and that is
let me paste this in the chat for you
all if for some reason you can't get
this link in the chat it's really easy
github.com slash Airbnb slash enzyme
okay so now I just
I'm skipping down to this to a section
that uses clickhandler
well we're good we're actually we're
gonna have to copy let's copy what we
have for I guess Tech section yeah let's
do text section let me check at bar as
well see we're doing
hmm I guess we can we can copy this
component and let's add a file here in
tes and this will be drawer item the
test is there we are
and I'm going to paste that in and I
should have changed it here as well okay
so we're not gonna have the same things
coming in like the same props for item
but we will have some that should be the
same so we could you know kind of put in
like primary text and let's see
yeah these submenu items are gonna be
what an array yeah we're gonna have to
pass in an array or we and that array is
gonna need to have things as well you
know we can we already have these arrays
made let's just grab it from our data
where's our data drawer menu
so in our drawer menu we can just grab a
few a few of these so let's just grab
two and then this will give us some good
test data let's get our our actual
component back to so we can look at it
yeah okay so within here we can say
looks where we had sub menu items sub
menu items and we should be able to just
give it its well let me double check was
it that er we need now we don't want
just an object we wanted array right
we want an array of objects okay and why
is this expression expected
oh okay that better
no okay
I do wrong that's a little weird I think
yeah my timer went off all right let me
take a short break and go back to the
the live chat here Phoenix says the link
has a 404 error try to copy and paste
the link for some reason clicking on
links in the in the chat it just it
doesn't work sometimes also check before
I forget
check out this shirt oh this is says
it's Ajax and it says Yolo and you it's
probably really hard to read but it says
you only load once I think it's funny I
got this at syntax con a couple years
ago and from there was a speaker Ben
Legba do from Eventbrite was giving out
t-shirts and so I got this one so if you
know anything about like jQuery AJAX you
can get data like how we use fetch
normally like before fetch you could
have used Ajax you can still use Ajax if
you already have jQuery loading but the
idea is you can get new data in or send
data out without having to load the page
like like a normally a form submission
would reload the page well with Ajax it
doesn't so I I thought it was kind of
clever that is one cool thing from
string of about stringing from home I
can wear coding t-shirts when I stream I
don't have to wear like a button-down
shirt or anything like that alright so
I'm gonna I'm trying to find a question
see mom Demba sorry if I'm
mispronouncing that says hello help me
I'm a beginner in programming okay I
mean let me know if you have any
specific questions I'd be happy to help
just let me know
Eddie asks if anyone uses webstorm is it
worth the $10 a month or should I just
use PS code I don't know that much about
webstorm so I don't know what it does
that official Studio code can't do I
would just check out the features if the
features that it has that are unique to
webstorm are really important for you
then maybe it is worth it $10 a month
but if you're if you're not even going
to use those extra features or if there
are like plug-ins for vs code or
something that can do the same thing
then just go with es code it's free and
it's really good all right Blake says
just sent you a DM and slack okay cool
I'll try to remember to check that out I
have all my slack windows closed for the
stream because I'm trying to run as
little as possible in the background
okay no bullying Savage is here what's
up Eddie says I've done testing with
Jasmine our enzyme ingest react specific
yeah what is it just I think just as
react specific if I'm correct just was
developed by Facebook for testing react
enzyme
I don't think enzyme is react specific
though an enzyme can be used with other
things besides jest so I'm pretty new to
testing though so I may be wrong about
enzyme I'm like 99% sure I'm right about
just though you can hear that noise
that's my kids running around right
above me as a the the room so my kid the
two girls have one room and the two boys
have another room so the boy's room is
right above me so evidently their
jumping is something like that
well John asked if I did the react
update yet since I doubt it would break
anything much no I didn't do the update
yet I I wanted to check I need to check
next and see cuz I don't think it would
break much either but the big thing is
would this does this version of next
work with that or do I need to wait for
whatever next is gonna do and I haven't
even checked on it they it may already
work I haven't checked it and then
material.you I came out with a new
update as well so I need to upgrade
those two things I totally forgot about
both upgrades though and so you just
said that so maybe that's what we'll do
tomorrow for the stream I'm interested
in your opinion though I've started
doing like upgrade streams where when
when kind of a more popular thing that
we're using comes out with an upgrade I
upgrade it on the stream and we work
through any issues together let me know
if that's useful to you all
I imagine especially if you're using
those and you haven't upgraded yet that
could help you avoid some problems but
you know for a lot of you if you don't
even use those I don't maybe it's not
that useful let me know if you like it
if you don't like it because I mean
obviously well we're always gonna have
updates that needs me done so I I don't
have to do it on the stream but if it
has value to you I definitely will keep
doing it let's see alright so we're
gonna go back to it I do have some
comments that have to do with what we
were just doing though Michael says did
you leave out a colon or equal after
submenu yeah let me see oops let me
restart this this timer we're gonna do
at least one more Pomodoro session and
trying to think I have an appointment at
5:00 that I need to get ready for so
yeah it's only it's about three o'clock
my time so if we do another Pomodoro
session
a little question answer session that
should give me enough time to get ready
so all right so let me check this out I
see James and and Phoenix and Aditya I
see your questions that just came in
there I'll get to those after this next
session so if you could just be patient
for about 25 more minutes I'll
definitely answer those questions but
let's see what I did here draw a test
okay so I just met some stuff up and I'm
not sure why so let's see what I did it
submenu items equal yeah this is weird
okay all right
string why is this no it's not supposed
to be a boolean I mean that maybe that's
part of the problem
it's expecting a boolean you know let's
see yeah now this is definitely supposed
to be an array all right let's see if we
can I don't know if we could do this or
not but let's see if we can do this
where we make a Const and this is test
array I would say test items equals and
then now let's put in all of this okay
and then now let's see if we can just
pass in test items whoops
and let's yeah let's see if we can do
this get this to work now
expected what did it expect not all
right let's put in our dollar sign see
still expected that what am I doing
wrong
okay I'm
I'm just gonna let this go for now and
see if this is just some something weird
that it's giving me
and that it'll still work I don't I
don't know we'll see all right it's the
last thing I want to do is let's just
take this out for not because I just
want to test it let's see what we get
pull this up so we can see more of it
all right cool we got it one failure
all right failed to run just expel you
should be either an expression or
quarter just text
oh let me get rid of this too though cuz
this shouldn't oh no no no this is
correct let's see
this is you're still not gonna work all
right let me go back to the docks done
because this is definitely not it's got
to be possible to pass in something
other than just a string
let me see what's a heck there we go
wait a second was I just losing my mind
I think I was because that's JSX so I
have to put stuff like never mind for
everybody that put back the curly back
I have Michael you're entirely correct
so for anybody watching this that's been
saying wow this guy's no clue what he's
doing for the last 10 minutes or more I
apologize the solution of that was just
so obvious I I don't know what I was
thinking okay let's run this I'm pretty
sure this will work now and then if this
does work the last thing we'll do is use
an on-click
did it fail again well two failed what
is this okay
oops looks like okay so it looks like
submenu items are you have to have them
that's actually not great behavior there
right I mean at as the components used
right now there's never a time when you
don't have any submenu items but this
component could be a lot more versatile
if it it was able to either just be a
standalone item or have sub items below
it so maybe let's take the first step in
making this component more useful in
different situations
and so let's say this list this call
this whole collapse yeah this whole
collapse component here is going to own
it's gonna render conditionally based on
if submenu item exists so we're gonna
say is menu items if submenu items yeah
we just we just need to check if it
exists right yeah and then maybe yeah we
can check all right let's just check
first and see if it exists and see if
that's enough where's okay just gonna
add that racket in here and take it out
of here
okay so now we're gonna save that and
let's run this again and see if we get
those same errors so what should happen
is we should not get those errors
anymore because it's not gonna try to
map through something that doesn't exist
it won't even try to render any of that
which I mean that's that's better right
even you know on the off chance that
this gets used without a sub menu item
then at least it won't cause an error
right users wouldn't see an error you
know they may see something that looks
like you can click it but when you do
nothing really happens which is better
than than getting an error because they
may not ever even try to click it let's
see what happened what failed is this
should render a title one passed there
okay so let's see what failed here
doesn't match the snapshot oh okay
because it already expected that all
right let's let's go ahead and do this
droid I'm Tess let's delete it yeah
let's run it again no that's not what I
wanted
no okay hold on do we have that still
you got to be kidding me I just deleted
the wrong thing all right see if I can
undo it
no I can't okay
Wow let's see and then you can get it
back I clicking on to get fourth icon
all right I'm Tess
[Music]
mmm-hmm it doesn't even have it in there
where you have the blue six all right
okay this one was a track by kid it
should have been all right can't believe
I deleted the wrong file
what I was trying to do was to delete
the snapshot so we would generate a new
one because I think some of the old
stuff that was generated was messing it
up okay let's see if there's any way I
can change this I I highly doubt that
this was if you delete something in
Visual Studio code I don't think that it
goes into like the the trash folder but
I guess it's worth a shot
to search for it sort of it
all right well yeah let's just let's
just do this again I'm gonna make a new
one and then I'm not gonna do all the
other stuff that we just did at first
what I'll do is just do the clickhandler
one
okay all right so let's take out most of
this just take this up to so I'm gonna
copy in some stuff and I don't
okay all right now let me copy over
something from the Airbnb enzyme Gabe
Rita
all right so let's see what I do okay
it's just the lines all right so I paste
it in it simulates click events so on
button click let's see I need to bring
in this is using actually that's using a
different let's look at the just one
all right let's see
maybe it'll work sorry what's confusing
me here is that we're importing this and
I'm not sure what it is so it doesn't
say yeah it doesn't say to actually
bring this in so I'm I'm just gonna try
to import it and see if we actually have
it somewhere with you know if it was
brought in with enzyme
and let's say all right so we
[Music]
similarly our there's two different
examples for how to do this trying to
figure out which one would be the better
one
I think we can let me try this one it
seems like it's a little bit more simple
but we're also gonna have to bring in
shallow as well
I checked my time only two minutes okay
- ringing a shallow we went to spy we
don't want this to be we want it to be
drawer item like a click so we want to
find
alright let's see we're not gonna call
it on button click that we're gonna call
it expand item actually no that's not
shoot this is giving me trouble let's
check out the API documentation so I'm
gonna I'm gonna paste in the a full API
documentation for amounts maybe I won't
paste it I'm not sure that this is going
to even be helpful
all right it's button we'd want to find
button what is this render to I guess we
can go back and we could do it the other
way now that I've seen both ways I think
it doesn't really matter so we'll just
keep it a little more simple here there
we go
we still want this to be drawer item
draw item on button click soon as this
is this going to be
this will be expanded item it's gonna
run that spy I guess and X back time I
click to have two property call one it's
not what we want
she really like the click and we're
gonna expect
really gonna expect expand more to be
present right
let's see let's expect this is goodness
from the tutorial so let's see states is
open to equal now what's this output is
not defined lost output English how
they're using the shell is um rapper
there we go alright let me run this see
if anything happens and then that'll be
all we do I don't expect this to work
I'm kind of mixing things from tutorials
and I'm not sure if they're using the
same versions
I'll definitely failed okay alright so
this thing definitely failed this spy
all right
oh they're alright so Maya timer went
off a while ago so I do want to get back
and answer questions because I I've
already gone over this time but
basically just to give you an idea of I
don't know if we'll do another show for
testing or not so what I'm obviously
what I'm trying to do is see like what
happens if you click the button in this
component does it actually do what it's
supposed to do and right now I don't
really know if this is gonna work right
cuz I guess I'll have to get this
package and test it out so I don't know
maybe this would work like this maybe it
wouldn't but that's the basic idea this
is you should be able to do this with
with enzyme and just to be able to test
things and right here what I'm checking
for is to see if the state actually
changes to what it should when this is
clicked on I guess yeah that's that
would probably be the thing to test and
then you know another test could be like
if the state is open is true you know
then is everything displayed properly so
that could potentially yeah that could
potentially be another test so I I don't
know that my first idea was to say like
if it's clicked then is all this stuff
displayed but I think that's skipping a
step in between I think you probably you
better to test to see that the state
changes first and then in another chest
see like okay if the state is that then
what happens and then it's broken down a
little bit more it would be easier to
pinpoint exactly where the issue is is
it changing the state that's the issue
or is it rendering based on a state
that's the issue okay hopefully that
makes some sense
I couldn't get it figured out let's let
me scroll up a bit and answer some
questions actually you know what I'm I
am going to you know what I don't want
to I'm gonna take I'm gonna comment this
out for now so that way it will be there
when I go to submit this but it won't
cause the test to fail so if anyone
wants to check it out I'm gonna push
this to the repo now so I don't forget
it's probably right after this I'm gonna
quit and start getting ready for my
appointment so it's likely I would
forget to push this so I'm gonna do it
while we're still here while that's
working I'm gonna try to answer some
questions okay so I left off right here
with James James Scott says as a
front-end dev that I still fail oh yeah
cuz I was trying to import this - James
quote James's question was as a
front-end dev do you do any back-end
coding on personal projects I'm having a
hard time balancing both considering I
want to be a front-end F I actually do
back in coding on work projects so my
title is front-end dev but I kind of
have to do I have to do both right okay
so we found some obsolete snapshots
let's get rid of those oh that's that's
the command I was forgetting to run I
just kept the leading snapshots there we
go alright so yeah I end up doing
backend stuff really balanced I don't
have a problem with the balance of it I
just I do what I have to do right so
whatever needs to get done for the
project to get done that's that's what I
do
thankfully I've had a lot of help from
you all
on the projects for the backend stuff
but sorry yeah it just it doesn't like
occur to me like whether I'm going
front-end or back-end or how much so I
guess you just you know you kind of do
what you have to do
Phoenix is what stack would you
recommend to become a full stack dev if
you're already did with JavaScript then
you may as well just go full stack
JavaScript and I mean if you like react
you can what do they call it burn stack
yeah like [ __ ] Express react node is
that what it is I think that's it yeah
but I mean I would go with some sort of
you know Chuck full stack JavaScript if
you happen to know a different back-end
language then maybe go with that that
would be your easiest route but I mean
if you were starting fresh I would still
say go with the full stack JavaScript a
lot of people are using it you can do
pretty much anything you want with it
and you only have to learn one language
alright we're gonna do a git status just
to see all the stuff that's changed
this looks good let's do get add and now
all everything's staged since we need to
get at now we're gonna do yarn CM
can you all hear my kids they're
upstairs well it's still pretty loud
alright let's see okay so we're gonna do
yarn CM this is gonna help us do a
commit message and we were doing tests
tests I thought we had Barry our test so
let's say add for text section and draw
right on didn't break anything I don't
think we have an issue for that okay so
that's gonna do its thing hopefully
everything will pass I did yes I am new
here what is enzyme ingest enzyme and
Jess are NPM packages to help you test
in this case react so justice built by
Facebook hmm spoke by Facebook to help
test reacts enzyme is built by Airbnb
and it can help you test not only react
but uh I think other things as well you
don't have to use them together but
they're what we are using these together
right now you can use enzyme with other
things as well so an enzyme makes it
easier to test so Facebook does
recommend using enzyme just because it
makes it a lot easier
all right Bhargav says is this android
studio can anybody tell me non Android
studio it's visual studio code
okay cool when Phoenix was offering some
answers there do a few questions as well
Thank You Phoenix okay
Aditya asks what is react Phoenix offers
an answer it's a JavaScript library used
for building UI components and is
maintained by Facebook for more you can
Google react and you'll get all the
details you need
yeah Facebook has a really good
documentation tutorial and explanation
of react this should be one of the first
results that comes up I try typing like
react Jas since react such a common word
you know may not immediately come up
with you know Facebook's react alright
so it looked like everything passed
which is awesome so you can see we ran
our unit test automatically and now we
have let's see another test here that we
didn't before and that's our drawer item
test and let's do it
Origen oh I restarted so I have to
re-enter my key here so let's let's do
that I gotta get my key first from
LastPass
all right there we are
okay now the code will be there and I'm
going to run SSH ads so I don't have to
put that back in there we are
yeah so now everything that we did today
is now updated on the github repo the
link is in the description feel free to
you know check it out use it on your own
projects contribute to this project
whatever you'd like to do with it
and definitely feel free to point out or
correct my mistakes definitely always
open for for input and criticism let's
see Michael says I've been playing
around with graph QL and can pull data
from your database that I can't figure
out how to build a schema on the
client-side and make it less edges and
nodes all the way down any ideas hmm I
don't know I haven't really thought
about that oh yeah I I don't have any
ideas right now okay I haven't really
thought about it
mmm I don't know if I get an idea before
in the stream I'll let you know but
that's odd that hadn't even occurred to
me to do that I think if that's possible
that's a good idea
Michael says this is why I don't do
tests I just write some stuff log
results and if it doesn't work start all
over again and Michael says that's
probably why I'm unemployed yeah I mean
it says seem to be a pain I think tests
will probably be something that once I
get used to writing them and get good at
them it will improve my coding it'll be
a good skill to have but it's just going
to take practice for me to get to that
point
it's just I'm gonna have to force myself
to do it it's gonna be probably similar
to when I first started using it and it
seemed like why can't I just code why do
I have to keep doing these commits all
the time and but now I'm so used to
committing it's not really a big deal
it's just it's like second nature and I
see the value in doing it I think
testing is probably probably similar to
that so I'm gonna try my best to stick
with it and not be tempted to just skip
it in an inch when I'm trying to go
faster I think in the long run it'll
probably if I can do it right and really
learn how to do testing well I think in
the long run it will end up saving time
darshan asks what's the difference
between full-stack JavaScript versus
myrn stack darshan says assuming the
same thing right yeah so for the myrn
stack is a type of stack that happens to
be full scale stack javascript so you
could also do what is it the mean stack
which would be [ __ ] [ __ ] Express
angular node and that would also be full
stack JavaScript and if you didn't want
to use react you could probably use view
which I've never heard anybody say but
would that be like the the mevin stack I
mean
vn if you wanted use pre-act the meppen
stack I don't these aren't real I've
never seen anybody used this last day
but yet so
myrn stack is full stack JavaScript but
there are other things you could use and
still be full stack JavaScript
all right Michael said okay I'll work on
the graph QL schema just didn't want to
do extra work if you've already done it
yeah and actually Michael at one point
we had the idea and we've kind of put it
to the side basically just for time
purposes and I kind of think that's
something we could do later but we had
the idea to do a graph QL server where
we could pull in data from different
parts and then make our own schema to
send into react so we wouldn't be
pulling things let's say like directly
from WordPress into react there would be
like an in between server then we could
make the scheme of whatever we wanted I
still would like to do that it's just
gonna take I think it's gonna take more
learning on my part to be able to make
that happen so I don't want to rush it
and and mess it up
all right Blake said sorry I wasn't
listening that's 15 minutes did you see
my comment about slack I did see it and
I already forgot about it so thanks for
bringing it up again I'll try to
remember to log into that the slack
Channel and check it out
Gil turd says please react to on dude
I'm not a glitch 'red I'm not really
sure what you're talking about
can you explain it a little bit I think
I'm missing something
okay Michael says that's exactly what I
was talking about okay cool um yeah so I
think it would be very useful to have
kind of that in-between survey it'll
just be kind of another layer of
abstraction so that at any point we
could change where our date has come
from coming from and it it won't at all
like we won't have to really change
anything on the react side of things we
would just probably change things in
that kind of in-between server that
graph QL server so I could see some
advantages to it like potentially it
could be faster it could be another
place to do caching
oh cool Michaels let me do that I'm so
much better with the backend stuff I'm
on awesome hey that's that's really
great yeah yeah if you can do that that
would be so cool let's see
okay glittered said it's a hilarious
song called I'm on do re is CS is
supposed to be like German for rise the
rise I don't know phoenixes don't mind
that's
nothing to do with we were doing here
okay thanks thanks Phoenix alright cool
so I've gotten to the bottom of the chat
here so we got through I think I got
through all the questions if I missed
your question uh very sorry about that
ask me again on another stream or you
know send me a DM on some social media
network and yeah so that's it for today
I think I should be able to stream
tomorrow and thank you all for all your
help thank you for your patience as we
kind of like just slowly learned more
about about testing you know I we got I
think we got close with the click thing
so hopefully you know I can work on that
more and maybe show you a solution
tomorrow let's see trying to find the
stop streaming button yeah so probably
be back tomorrow I'm not exactly sure
what time I'm thinking maybe afternoon
in the Eastern time so maybe like 1 or 2
or something like that until then thanks
again for watching and have a great day